before in April 1954 the common belief
the universe will believe because it had
been tried again and again and again and
people that fail the belief was that man
was not physically capable of breaking
the four-minute barrier that he could
not run a mile in less than four minutes
when something happens to them they
began to believe that that's the way it
is that's the way it's always been and
they can't see the possibility of it
being any different 50 yards to go and
Bannister takes over
watch his John's try taking to the front
as he races the last long listing roger
bannister came along and he broke the
four-minute barrier since that time up
to this day over 20,000 people have done
it including high school kids 20,000
people what changed here's what happened
when they got on the track they knew it
had been done and because I knew it
and on there was a new belief
about this barrier that was unreachable
and those 20,000 people got in a raised
believing knowing in their heart that
someone had done it that it's possible
that they could do it if someone can
make that dream become a reality but you
can make your dream become real
you
eyesight and mindsight
eyesight is judging on what you see
judging according to appearances but my
insight is how you interpret what you
see one guy said it's not possible it's
over I'm finished I can't do it I can't
make it he's surrender I've faced
rejection again and again I'm not going
anymore there are no jobs out there but
this other guy he felt that in spite of
the knows and rejections in spite of how
bad the economy is in spite of what the
newspapers are saying that it's possible
that somebody somewhere will give me a
job he just kept on thinking it was
possible guess what ladies and gentlemen
that's what we have to do with our
dreams because things happen to you life
that you can never ever anticipate and
many times when those things happen you
want to give up easy is not an option
it's hard living life is not since log
when when you are 49 years old and
working on a job for 17 years and they
come in and tell you you're finished and
give you one week severance pay you have
to start all over again
it's not handling just the tragedies of
life it's hard when you're working on
something in and you put everything you
have in it and it doesn't work out you
lose your money and other people's money
know what I discovered when you working
at your dream somebody said the heart of
the battle the sweeter the victory it's
good to you I see what you becoming a
process is more important in the dream
that's far more important the kind of
person you become the character that you
build the courage that you develop the
faith that you're manifesting oh it's
it's something that you get up in the
morning you look yourself in the mirror
you're a different kind of person you
walk with a different kind of spirit
you've got to have that kind of courage
that type of determination if you want
to make it happen it's you you've got to
take personal responsibility to make it
happen
you must have faith you've gotta believe
in yourself you've gotta believe in your
abilities you got to believe in your
service your company your ideas
unquestionably you got to have faith
and that fate gives you patience it's
not going to happen as quickly if you
want to have
it's your dream if we wanted to have it
get your butt up and make it happen if
we wanted to have it rise and ride I'm
tell you not to go back to school I dare
you to get up and I dare you to chase
your dream it's possible you could win
whatever comes to you don't run from it
don't try and duck it like most people
do just water
you want to make a dream come true you
got to stay focused some people ever get
even than get ahead stay focus on where
you want to go
where are you going with your life
you